o olá tudo bem muito prazer eu sou
thiago lopes eu mostro o mundo de forma
positiva eu quero te mostrar agora um
milhão e um motivos 1 milhão e uma
opções para você voltar a viajar tá eu
sei que pode ser que viajar seja a
última coisa que você esteja pensando
nesse momento outro você nem tem a
vontade mas essa hora vai chegar no fim
da apresentação eu quero te fazer um
convite que eu acredito que assim como
eu muita gente tem o desejo de viajar de
conhecer lugares novos bom primeiro
deixe-me apresentar para você me
conhecer melhor né eu nasci numa
cidadezinha no interior de minas gerais
se chama campo belo perto de varginha
mas já faz 15 anos que eu tô morando
aqui em são paulo eu sou influenciador
de viagens youtuber turismólogo
apresentador mestre de cerimônia
palestrante misturando tudo isso eu sou
um comunicador que foca
e as coisas e quer coisa melhor nessa
vida do que viajar faz tão bem e o tanto
de gente que gosta você faz ideia
quantas pessoas no mundo gostam de
viajar por ano um milhão e meio de
pessoas isso é mais do que toda a
população da china desse total 109
milhões são brasileiros sendo 12 milhões
de brasileiros que viajam para o
exterior isso é uma população de são
paulo toda eu sou um desses 12 milhões
de brasileiros que viajam pelo mundo a
última viagem que eu fiz para mostrar o
mundo de forma positiva no meu canal eu
fui para os estados unidos na disney e
eu pousei de volta no brasil no
aeroporto de guarulhos no dia vinte e
dois de fevereiro de 2020 eu teria 20
dias no brasil e já viajaria de volta
para um festival de música eletrônica de
inverno nos alpes franceses inclusive eu
já fiz um vídeo desse mesmo festival
quando ele aconteceu no brasil que teve
mais de
15 milhões de visualizações mas o
festival na neve foi cancelado assim
como todas as minhas outras viagens
nesse momento todos os destinos mais
visitados do mundo foram-se fechando um
a um só para você ter uma ideia o
coliseu que o atrativo turístico mais
popular do mundo segundo o tripadvisor
tava assim e ele ficou assim a frança
que é o lugar mais visitado do mundo tem
a torre eiffel tava assim e ficou assim
a times square em nova york tava sem e
ficou assim e eu tava assim eu fiquei
assim em casa comecei a minha 40 anos
tudo parou eu tive que parar também né
que que aconteceu nessa quarentena uma
saudade de uma aglomeração né minha
filha e aí eu tive que ter criatividade
para continuar alimentando de forma
positiva o meu canal no youtube então eu
juntei todos os meus imãs de geladeira
das minhas viagens e criem um stop
motion
quem sabe que é um stop motion é isso dá
um trabalho para fazer esse vídeo isso
me ajudava a fazer o tempo passar não
ficar pensando besteira só que de
repente não dava para fugir a quarentena
dura muito tempo e nela eu percebi a
realidade que é o desafio de ficar
sozinho mas fica sozinho faz parte né
então eu precisei buscar uma melhor
versão minha pro conseguir conviver
comigo mesmo e aí vem um processo de
redescoberta e redescobrir é ter que
começar tudo de novo e começar tudo de
novo é uma nova possibilidade de uma
solução melhor e é também a frase do meu
canal vamos começar tudo de novo nesse
momento foi como colocar um óculos pela
primeira vez de repente você percebe que
uma vida difusa em certa começa a entrar
no foco
e esse aqui é um óculos para enxergar
oportunidades foi quando eu conseguir
colocar esses óculos que eu percebi o
impacto que essa crise gerou na minha
vida mas crise é uma coisa que traz
oportunidades para gente então eu
comecei a repensar a refletir para poder
voltar melhor né era hora de refazer não
só os planos de vida como também os
planos de viagem mas eu precisava
entender o que tinha acontecido no
turismo no mundo e eu percebi que o
turismo é o setor econômico mais afetado
de todos e como é que ficou com convite
as coisas mudaram um estudo feito pela
fgv mostra como que vai ser que nós
vamos ter que passar por três períodos
primeiro período o isolamento social
onde tudo parou perceba que a queda no
gráfico segundo período é a
estabilização essa parte amarela é aqui
que pode durar cerca de um ano que vem a
retomada do turismo o reequilíbrio dos
negócios até zerar a perda causada
devido a pandemia
aí vem o terceiro período que a
recuperação aqui o turismo internacional
pode demorar até 18 meses para se
recuperar quem vai se recuperar primeiro
o turismo nacional então nós seremos
brasileiros viajando pelo brasil
parabéns você ganhou oportunidade de
conhecer melhor esse país lindo e olha
só que curioso que eu descobri eu
percebi que o gráfico dele estava
parecido com gráfico de monetização do
meu canal olha aqui o primeiro período a
queda o segundo período a retomada aqui
e faz sentido isso porque as empresas de
turismo pararam um pouco de anunciar
ainda mais nos meus vídeos que são de
viagens cidades festivais eventos
parques hotéis esses anúncios são muito
importantes ali mas perceba que o
gráfico que ó tá crescendo novamente e
como será o que que vai mudar quando a
gente passa por momentos delicados
o que é que a gente relembra o quantas
pessoas são mais importantes do que as
coisas o turismo que não preservaram as
pessoas não vai sobreviver por isso que
as empresas de ônibus das companhias
aéreas estão bastante rígidas com os
cuidados sanitários os hotéis também
isso é bom isso mostra que eles estão
preocupados de verdade só vai se
sustentar aquele turismo que despertar a
confiança no viajante as medidas básicas
o controle restrição de pessoas que
também vai ser necessário mas quer coisa
melhor que chegar no destino com poucas
pessoas pensa como que vai ser chegar
numa das sete maravilhas do mundo o
cristo redentor e de lá dá para ver o
pão de açúcar imagino como que vai ser
pegar um bondinho uma coisa boa que as
pessoas vão ficar com medo achando que o
bondinho vai cair porque tá lotado tem
afinal ele vai estar comendo as pessoas
ou seja nós teremos doses homeopáticas
de turismo o turismo aos pouquinhos eu
confesso que eu prefiro um lugar mais
é mas eu respeito eu entendo quem
prefere uma aglomeração lugar lotado
aquela fila grande hashtag gente suada
para mim perrengue chique é só no
instagram no começo nessa retomada nós
teremos viajantes digitais vamos
perceber uma automação dos serviços o
atendimento ao cliente deve passado
físico para o virtual por exemplo nos
restaurantes a gente deve pedir a comida
pelos aplicativos só para não ter que
encostar no cardápio só que aí você tá
pedindo a comida quando acabou a bateria
do celular você esqueceu o carregador e
esqueceu também um carregador portátil
cada país tô tomando um tipo de medida a
china lá eles criaram uma identidade
digital que é um qr code que mostra o
seu histórico de viagem seu histórico
médico e isso gera diferentes cores se
der a cor verde você tem permissão para
entrar no aeroporto nos parques
temáticos nos shoppings
e bora se der amarelo ou vermelho você
tem restrições isso parece um feriado
mas não é isso é a china as maldivas um
dos lugares mais luxuosos do mundo além
de pedir os testes antes eles removeram
a taxa de turista as autoridades do
chipre elas estão muito ansiosas eles
estão se oferecendo a cobrir os custos
dos viajantes que se infectarem durante
a visita no país em aruba no caribe eles
criaram uma certificação de limpeza e
desinfecção chama-se código de saúde e
felicidade uma forma de ressignificar
essa tristeza que lindo isso o brasil
criou o selo de responsabilidade que é
um incentivo para dar credibilidade e
confiança para gente voltar a viajar
percebemos então que cada lugar do mundo
tá fazendo de um jeito que não tem um
método específico para ser seguido e faz
sentido isso né porque cada de
é um jeito como a gente acabou de falar
do brasil é sobre o brasil que eu quero
falar saíram algumas pesquisas que
mostram a quantidade de pessoas que já
querem viajar e o curioso é para onde
esses brasileiros querem viajar sabe
para onde para o nosso país em primeiro
lugar está aqui o nordeste com 27 por
cento em segundo lugar vem as praias
regionais com quatorze por cento tam tam
tam tam tam e agora chegou a hora que eu
vou te mostrar que no brasil nós temos
um milhão e um motivos 1 milhão e uma
oportunidade um milhão e uma
possibilidades de viajar duas coisas
você sabia que o brasil foi considerado
o país com maior potencial de ecoturismo
do mundo pelo fórum econômico mundial a
segunda coisa temos aqui alguns destinos
e quantos milhões de turistas
estrangeiros eles recebem o brasil
recebe c
a 6 milhões de turistas estrangeiros a
maioria deles são argentinos e que já
ficam lá pelo sul dizem até que santa
catarina é a praia do argentino porque
você anda lá para todo ladrão pero que
si pero que noa é hora da gente colocar
os óculos da oportunidade porque você
ganhou a chance de lembrar o quanto o
brasil tem de bom para conhecer no
território brasileiro temos oito milhões
e meio de quilômetros quadrados de
extensão distribuídos em 26 estados e um
distrito federal temos no total 5.570
municípios só que cada município cada
cidade tem alguma coisa em comum outra
cidade mas o que então eu fui lá no meu
instagram meu instagram thiago lopes e
perguntei os meus amigos o que que toda
a cidade tem em comum e eles responderam
e eu acho que você vai concordar comigo
que toda a cidade tem alguma igreja tem
um restaurante local tem alguma feirinha
o
e tem umas pracinhas e tem algum
cachorro nessas pracinhas que podem ser
adotado agora vamos aos números só para
você entender esses números é uma forma
que eu encontrei para poder te explicar
e se humilham e o motivos só em são
paulo nós temos 5779 igrejas para 12
milhões de pessoas fazendo uma regrinha
de três com população do brasil que é de
211 milhões devemos ter cerca de 100 mil
e 400 igrejas existem no brasil ativos
mais de 300 mil restaurantes feirinha
mercado mercado municipal mercadão eu
entendo que cada cidade deve ter um em
são paulo e capitais tem centenas mas
vamos considerar um só porque deve ter
lugar que não tem nenhuma feirinha legal
para se ver então 5.570 somente graças
em tudo quanto é bairro né mas quantos
bairros tem numa
em goiânia tem 640 e tantos bairros rio
de janeiro e salvador mais de 160
não-me-toque não-me-toque a uma
cidadezinha lá do sul do país que tem 17
mil habitantes e tem 16 bairros tomo
considerar que nem todo bairro tem uma
praça para você ir lá visitar então
vamos considerar apenas dez bairros 10
praças por cidade muitas cidades tem
algum museu alguma casa da cultura
alguns centro cultural teatros eu
acredito que muitas cidades do brasil
não deve ter nenhum então vamos
considerar só um por cidade outra coisa
que nós temos são os atrativos cada
cidade do brasil tem algum marco zero o
monumento principal algum obelisco temos
arquitetura local só de hotéis nós temos
mais de 10 mil e quinhentos no brasil
ativos pousadas parques aquáticos
temáticos resorts e te
e os atrativos que são os nossos bens
mais valiosos as belezas naturais do
brasil tem as florestas os rios
cristalinos as lagoas e todos esses
atrativos que você tá vendo no slide aí
eu coloquei o sinal de mais aqui porque
não dá nem para quantificar quanto os
atrativos nós temos realmente eu ainda
não falei do atrativo mais popular do
brasil que são as praias nós temos o 16º
litoral mais extenso do mundo no total
7.400 km de extensão e nesse litoral nós
temos 2095 praias isso sem contar as
praias de água doce e temos também as
cachoeiras em apenas quatro chapadas das
sete chapadas que nós temos no brasil
somam quase mil cachoeiras e as
cachoeiras ainda estão sendo descobertas
até hoje para
o número aqui eu fiz uma comparação com
os números de ilhabela que tem 40
praias-360 cachoeiras fazendo uma
regrinha de três nós devemos ter cerca
de 18885 cachoeiras só que tem um
detalhe em cada uma cachoeira nós
podemos ter várias possibilidades
turísticas pode rolar sei lá o arvorismo
bóia-cross um mergulho do outro lado de
repente o tamanho da cachoeira ou seja é
impossível encontrar quantidade de
atrativos turísticos que nós temos e por
último só no ano passado o brasil
recebeu cerca de 700 mil eventos esse
número ultrapassa em muito 1 milhão por
isso um milhão e um motivos porque há
mais de 1 milhão de possibilidades
turísticas que nós temos você pode
pensar que eu tô falando tudo isso um
jeito positivo demais e eu entendo que é
desafiador pensar positivo diante da
quantidade de notícias negativas que
quem sabe diariamente mas para pensar e
perceber o mundo de forma positiva eu
tive que trabalhar meu pensamento é como
se fosse um músculo que você tem que ir
na academia todos os dias para esse
músculo ficar forte é exercício diário é
com persistência só que isso me traz
qualidade de vida mais bem-estar mais
experiências positivas um pesquisador
ele fez um estudo analisando a relação
entre o dinheiro ea felicidade e ele
concluiu que experiências como viagens
traz muito mais felicidade do que
comprar bens materiais e que a
felicidade é mais duradoura e faz
sentido isso que se a gente consegue
superar as adversidades superar os
perrengues das viagens a gente pode
superar muito mais a gente vai voltar a
viajar de um jeito diferente então eu
posso te dar um conselho viaja para
lugares próximos de onde você mora por
enquanto e agora eu quero te fazer um
convite esse é o nosso
e para poder plantar para o brasil se
transformar no grande potencial que ele
tem para ser mas como eu sou thiago
lopes é simples isso sabe aqueles vídeos
fotos que estão circulando pela internet
mostrando veneza com água mais
transparente imagens de drones mostrando
os destinos mesmo que vasinhos dá uma
vontade de conhecer aqueles lugares não
dá
e é isso é isso que nós vamos fazer
vamos viajar e divulgar o brasil nas
suas redes sociais do seu jeito é só
você lembrar de colocar hashtag nome do
local para ficar fácil de achar quanto
mais conteúdo mais chance de alguém ver
e é comprovado que o crescimento do
turismo está fortemente ligado a
promoção dos destinos bora trazer os
gringos para conhecerem o brasil e assim
a gente vai estar ajudando inclusive
aqueles que sobrevivem do turismo nesse
momento isolamento eu acredito que assim
como eu você percebeu o quanto é
importante ter pessoas o quanto é
importante valorizar as pessoas que
estão ao nosso lado e o meu convite é
justamente esse para você valorizar os
lugares que estão ao seu lado permita-se
conhecer o brasil seja bem-vindo ao novo
normal agora é hora de você vestir os
óculos e enxergar as oportunidades mas
nunca se esqueça vamos com
oi tudo de novo obrigado
e aí